yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
if you've ever had a pet you've probably
wondered what it's thinking or what it
gets up to when you're not there and
that's essentially the premise of the
secret life of pets
basically it's Toy Story for our
four-legged furry or feathered friends
the movie features lots of cool
characters who are interestingly
designed and smartly voiced by a cast of
well-known actors including comedian
Louie CK and modern families Eric
Stonestreet who lend their vocal chords
to the movies to Maine Purchase Max and
Duke I also loved Lake Bell as the fat
cat Chloe and Jenny slate who did the
voice of bellwether and Zootopia is
wonderful as a super fluffy but badass
Pomeranian called Gidget who adores
telenovelas Kevin Hart is also just
flat-out fantastic as incredibly fluffy
and equally insane bunny snowball and
Albert Brooks who you loved heard as
Marlon in finding Nero and finding dory
is reliably on form as the hungry hawk
Tiberius screenwriters Ken Dario and
Cinco Paul who did the despicable Me
movies and Brian Lynch who did minions
give us a script that keeps at the pace
to route moving forward with plenty of
action and lots of laughs including
visual comedy animal behavior based gags
and some amusing nods to other movies
speaking of which look out for my video
on this movie's Easter eggs and
references lewiston superb set pieces
and montages right from the start where
were introduced to the movie's main pets
there's also a clever scene which shows
the ingenious ways that pets get around
the city and a crazy funny fantasy
sequence directors Chris Renault and
yarrow Cheney do a good job keeping us
entertained during the movies 90 minute
runtime though the film doesn't quite
have the depth heart or emotion of
Pixar's best movies and its story beats
do feel pretty familiar animation wise
the movies really bright and colorful
and gives us a rather beautiful version
of New York in fact there's a gorgeous
shot that flies through New York City at
the start giving us all the typical
sights you know the Statue of Liberty
Brooklyn Bridge the yellow cabs the
Empire State Central Park and so on but
it's all gorgeously lit basically if you
enjoyed the Despicable Me and minions
movies and odds-on you'll enjoy this too
and I can definitely see them making
more of these The Secret Life of pets
movies in future Owen
before the secret life of pets starts
begin a short film called MOA minions
featuring everyone's favorite banana
loving mischief-makers who proved to be
as much fun as ever and it's nice to see
them again ahead of next summer's
Despicable Me 3 so to sum up the secret
life of pets is a colorfully animated
vibrant and energetically paced feature
which pulls back the curtain on what our
pets get up to when left alone in terms
of story and emotion it doesn't quite
reach the level of the thematically
similar Toy Story or fellow animal
features Zootopia however it is a
charming flick with some fab characters
and voice cast and a bundle of laughs
and we get an added minions shorts so
what's not to like the secret life of
pets gets three and a half out of 5
flicks now what did you think of the
secret life of pets and the minions
short and what would you like to see in
Despicable Me 3 let me know in the
comments below
if you liked this review I'd love it if
you'd share it and do subscribe for more
movie reviews Easter egg videos and
amazing movie facts click the links here
to check those out thanks for watching
and see you next time you'll be going
movie lovers